you know I did a thousand films over
about a six year period you had to have
a current
um like full panel like STD and AIDS
test you would look is the test clear
great and that's what I would know about
the girl until I walked into the room
and had sex with her
[Music]
when I was a teenage boy I thought there
were certain jobs that were probably a
lot of fun being an astronaut was
probably one of them being I don't know
a competitive Surfer that seemed kind of
cool and of course every teenage boy
thinks man what would it be like to be a
porn star that's got to be kind of crazy
huh boy wouldn't that be a great job
uh that was not my calling I probably
didn't you know I don't I'm not like the
most muscular guy in the world probably
wasn't wasn't going to happen and
probably I think in retrospect that's a
good thing I am joined today however by
someone who did become a porn star and
who became the top porn star in the
world won the award whatever the award
is for top porn star he won it that
would be Joshua Broome turned out the
job was not all teenage boys might think
it would be cracked up to be Joshua
thank you for coming on the show glad to
be here so
I'm pleased to say
for all my sins I'm not familiar with
your work okay and but I was talking to
some people who are familiar with your
work okay and you were not just a guy
who
did a porn movie or two right
you were a big guy in this industry yeah
you made it to the top of the industry
yeah
one how the hell do you get involved in
that kind of thing and then how'd you
get out yeah so uh from a big picture
standpoint I got in the industry by
thinking you know okay someone who is in
the acting and modeling industry if I
put myself in closer proximity to the
industry that I wanted to be in it would
make sense it would make you know me
getting jobs easier so I did that and it
worked I got an agent so I was
predominantly doing some Runway along
with some print and then commercials and
stuff like that having this aspiring
actor not acting very much but I had a
real had an agent had a lot of
aspirations which is more than most
actors yeah yeah I was doing it and yeah
auditioning yeah yeah 100 I was doing
well like there was there was no reason
to make the decision that I made because
a lot of people would say you know I
needed money I needed to do this or
there was some kind of trauma you know
that there was nothing pointing me to
that direction yet I found myself there
But to answer your question I move out
to Hollywood like many other people
you're pursuing your dream but you need
to do something to mediate your expenses
so I found myself working at a
restaurant and in that restaurant three
girls sat down there were these
beautiful girls and I go over to them
and I thought you know maybe I'll get
their number or a good tip or whatever
and they invite me to meet with their
agent and they ask me if I want to be an
actor and I'm like yes you know this is
a great opportunity for me maybe they're
working on a project or maybe they know
a casting director or something that
like that but they're like no no we're
talking about pornography and I was like
I never considered it but I was very
intrigued and being someone
um you know I didn't have a reason to
say no so I said sure I'll meet with
your agent and I meet with this agent
and he was like
um he asked me three questions he asked
me uh what did my upbringing look like
you know how did I grow up uh what was I
doing in LA and what did I hope to
accomplish and I was like well I grew up
you know pretty much just me and my mom
and I want to be an actor so that's why
that's why I'm here and I guess what I
want to accomplish is uh to be famous
and he was like perfect uh you know I
can make your name famous yeah you'll
make you know x amount of dollars and
then it actually is advantageous for you
that you have this acting background
because the pornography industry is is
shifting from just making these like
one-off scenes where they're parodying
movies in their scripts and and all the
stuff so you if you have acting
experience and you can bring that into
that it'll be great there'll be you know
a great runway for you to have all the
things that you said you wanted so being
someone who's naive and didn't really
have a good foundation to say no I was
like well how how big of a deal could it
be if I do one right and then that one
uh it you know for a lack of better
terms you know even it was like 2006
went viral so like 500 000 views back
then massive and uh very quickly I have
an agent that I beg to represent me
calling me saying that they can't
represent me anymore because they don't
want to be associated with my likeness
so you're a legit acting age right says
I'm dumb so you you sign up with the
porn agency you do the scene
in order to help your mainstream acting
career and then as a result of that you
become so famous that your mainstream
agent dumps you yeah I'm gonna go back
to that yeah it was three questions sure
sure I asked you so I get the latter two
questions yeah what are you doing here
what do you want to accomplish where do
you see yourself
what about that first question why did
he ask you that first question about
your childhood and
how did you give him the the answer that
he was looking for yeah I mean I I think
in a in in retrospect it was how can I
manipulate you
you know so for me saying okay I'm from
a broken home yeah you didn't have a
father you probably didn't have
leadership you probably are looking to
prove something or looking to find
something I can take that want in that
desire and if I if I tell them something
that's affirming which is an innate
desire that you know exists in each and
every person like you want to be
affirmed you want to feel loved you want
to feel like you matter and those are
good things but if they're manipulated
they'll lead you down a path that you
never intended to go
how common is that in in porn is it just
across the board everybody comes across
the board because at the end of the day
when you lay your head down on a pillow
it doesn't matter how much money is in
your bank account like no one wants to
be a prostitute right like no one
desires that no one is regardless of
what you say like if someone's addicted
to pornography and you know they believe
the lie to be true is that you know it's
this will be fun this will be this this
will be that if you believe that to be a
real reality like sure might someone
might say I want to do this yeah but no
one seeks out that yeah
but people do seek out Fame sure and
they do and what's really interesting
about your story is often you will hear
female porn stars yeah later on say I
was abused this was terrible of course
of course that's the case men and women
are different and women are abused it
would seem much more by the industry
you don't hear it as much from the men
and you think well men we can kind of
divorce sex from our emotional life and
oh man you know we just get the fun part
of everything and yeah but
porn wrecked you too yeah 100 I would
say uh it wrecks everyone because if if
you operate in a way that's
contradictory to the way that you were
wired to operate
the the byproduct of that is there's
going to be significant trauma mentally
and emotionally and regardless of if you
choose to suppress that and what that
might look like in in your life
practically that's probably gonna be
different from person to person but you
don't live that life and go and be
healthy unless you deal with that so you
you agree to do the scene yeah it goes
viral it goes viral and then my aging is
like well my agent calls me they had
come to know that that happened and then
a few weeks later something probably
even worse for me
my mom calls me and she's like well your
uncle said that someone at work told him
that yeah I had done a a porn movie oh
and I I was humiliated oh and for me
personally like my mom had me when she
was 16 and uh she made significant
sacrifices for the things that we had
and when I started pursuing modeling and
acting that started at 13 so getting
comp cards getting head shots you know
do like I I didn't talk the way that I
talked now it's like I was very like I
grew up in a really small town in South
Carolina like I couldn't I said like
they made up words that my grandma would
say like Mater and tater like
um super Country Bumpkin so I did all
these things that my mom really couldn't
afford but she made a way because she
wanted me to have a better life than she
did and it was something I was
passionate about and she did everything
that she could to provide for me and yet
I found myself squandering those things
the the equity that we gained along the
way
um I it just kind of
blew up so you have this phone call with
your mother yeah is it a sort of I'm
never speaking to you again or is it a
yeah so you're doing this job so if our
mom my mom even Keel all the way
um she's like Joshua Luke so growing up
in the South like Joshua like you know
you're okay Joshua Luke uh you know you
you better heighten your awareness
Joshua Luke Broome you run you know so
she was just like Joshua Luke broom like
why would you do that it's like I love
you but you are better than that
and I think that's something that you
have to wrestle with in your life but
you know in some aspects someone you'll
you'll make a decision that leaves you
at a Crossroads and someone uh in your
life hopefully is going to say uh here's
a better way if you've compromised or
you've done something that you shouldn't
have done uh that you messed up and now
you're at a fork in a road and you
you're having this conversation with
someone it's like okay this is what you
should do but it's going to require
change it's going to require hard work
and it's so much easier to not do the
hard work change directions do do
whatever needs to be done to you know
change change the direction that you're
going so I chose to you know push her
away even though she was saying I love
you that was a response I love you but
you're better than that why would you do
that you just squandered everything that
you've worked for the last you know
almost 10 years right right but you got
one thing you wanted which is you got
Fame sure did you get money is the money
any good or no for I mean it's it's
almost like a personal trainer so a
personal trainer that works at you know
LA Fitness uh probably makes eight or
nine dollars an hour and they get they
don't get paid so like you charge seven
eight hundred dollars a person for
personal training they don't get that
money the organization gets that money
and they get an hourly rate right
um but if you are and you know if you
start personal training on your own and
you're like paying a gym you know a fee
and you're you can make money that way
but my point is some personal trainers
will make two three four hundred
thousand dollars a year and some
personal trainers will make 30. yeah so
this porn's the same way if if you are
in demand you can charge more and how
much you work is dependent on you it's
just like that just like the regular
like acting or or any other like any
industry I guess yeah yeah if if you're
good at your trade and there's a demand
you can charge more money and if there's
a demand you'll work more and that was
my case where I was you know I did a
thousand films over about a six year
period wow and for me so many days a
week are you working so I'm doing like
20 25 films a month whoa so you're
working like every day yeah it was just
it just becomes something that was
incredibly monotonous you know like I
would show up the set and you know do
what I was paid to do and and go about
my business did you know these girls I
mean you uh so in the industry there's
uh like 30 to 40 guys that work all the
time and there's just a constant influx
of girls
um I would say even when I was in the
industry there's not like a superstar
that was like days of old
um because it's so saturated that people
are you know neurologically you you get
that you know that dopamine hit to your
synapse and you're looking but you're
always looking for new and you're
looking for more so the girls are you
know constantly evolving and the guys
don't matter as much yeah but for a
director standpoint so a director is
more often than not there's a production
company that has he has a deal with and
then director hires Talent puts together
a film gets it edited and hands it back
to the production company right so all
the weight is on the director to get
this film done so if you hire a guy that
can't do the job then there's no product
yeah so you just squandered twenty
thirty thousand dollars
because everyone else is getting paid no
matter what because everyone else did
their job but the guy didn't so the guy
is the only person at risk of not
getting paid so what the directors would
do they will find like five to ten guys
that they hire on a consistent basis and
those will be the guys they hire every
single time so that's why I was shooting
so much I just became reliable one of
the reli yeah there was there was
nothing special about me it's like for
me in that industry that was full of
people who you know had significant
trauma that had drug problems you know
like you name it I was just a normal guy
that took my job seriously I showed up
on time I did what I was supposed to do
and I didn't cause any problems so
during this time you're you're not
addicted to drugs you're not falling
into these vices that are traditionally
associated with yeah so for me is
interesting because I'm someone who's
incredibly extroverted but I found
myself because you you're you're so
exposed when you're doing it's like you
the last thing you want to do is be
around people really
um so I I found myself I I wouldn't go
to parties or or anything like that
unless I was being paid to make an
appearance or something like that I I
was you know pretty much a recluse
so you're you're working in the industry
yeah there's this steady stream of girls
coming in yeah what is the relationship
like when the cameras are off yeah
between the guys and the girls in the
industry did you did you have any qualms
about
these girls are obviously very damaged
people yeah or is it just uh oh hi nice
to meet you okay we're gonna go do our
job now and you know see you next time
well if if you if you uh if you get rid
of the introduction and the
and really in the exit yeah so I mean
literally so the way the way that a
normal scene would work is the director
is going to shoot something called
pretty girls and it's just uh just
photos of the girl and then you would
come in and you would take photos with
the girl and then you would leave and
then you would just walk into the room
like there's like the only thing I knew
about the girl is her legal name and the
fact that you know you had to have a
current
um like full panel like STD and AIDS
test so that had to be current so every
21 days you had to have a new test so
you would you would look do the IDS Max
match the test is the test clear great
and that's what I would know about the
girl until I walked into the room and
had sex with her
and then the guys were taking erectile
dysfunction medication the girls were
using Lube or no or numbing cream it was
it was so far from anything that was
remotely intimate
so was the byproduct of you being in
proximity Is people like do people end
up dating sure but who else are you
going to date right you know like
there's no girl out there that's going
to be okay for and I mean in certain
scenarios sure but there's no legitimate
relationship happening outside of
someone who's spending time in that
industry so you would start dating and
this for me was really detrimental uh
mentally so you're dating someone and so
I'm I'm dating a girl we've been dating
for you know a little over a year she's
popular I'm popular and we're of course
like friends I'm friends with the other
guys in the industry because we're
around each other so who else so now
you're sitting at dinner with me and my
girlfriend and him and his girlfriend he
had sex with my girlfriend today and I
had sex with his girlfriend yesterday
and we're sitting there pretending that
we're in a monotonous you know
monogamous relationship and it's it's
it's all fine because it's just work and
the the impact that has on you mentally
and emotionally suppressing reality
is so destructive
and Michael to be honest like me 30
people I mean we can we can touch on
this a little bit later but 30 people
that I knew I knew their fur their real
names I knew things about them
um 30 people since I got out of the
industry I got out of the industry about
11 years ago have taken their life
either suicide or overdose
and it's because more often not the
girls there's a there's a common
trajectory it's a girl gets in the
industry she becomes popular and then
the agent has the girl fill out some
stuff and you have a no list and this no
list is is uh you know I'm not willing
to do certain things that's why I say
don't want to do gay stuffers right or I
mean for girls it's like anal and it's
pretty like it's crazy because
um like these identity factors that
you're you're placating
aspects of people I people's identity
and you're making them genres of
pornography like you know it's like like
inner like for example interracial porn
is not interracial porn it's
specifically any other race with a black
man huh across the board
like that's interracial porn which is
incredibly not like a white guy in a
black right it doesn't yeah if it's a
white guy and a black girl it's not
interracial which is insane it makes no
sense right right it's like blade but
it's just a specific sure fetish or
something yeah yeah I mean yeah all
these all these niches become you know
but but I say that to say so these girls
say I don't want to do X Y and Z and
they become popular and their popularity
tapers off some and their agent goes to
different Studios it's like well
how much would you pay
for this girl to do this thing that she
hasn't done yet because there's this
novelty to it because she hasn't done it
because people know that she says right
this is on my no list yeah well because
you don't see her in these right and but
what happens is the agent goes to the
studio and auctions off this thing that
she doesn't want to do and then the
agent comes back to the girl and says
hey
um I know you have been working as much
lately but this studio just reached out
to me and if you'd be willing to do this
thing that's on your no list they want
to give you fifty thousand dollars and
you'll become relevant again what do you
think and and then she does it and then
it becomes normalized yeah and then
there's no Allure to it anymore now it's
just something that she does and all
those things on the list she eventually
does them
and then in addition to that the agent
there's a he also has an escorting
agency which is glamorized prostitution
right where he's essentially selling
this girl at sex trafficking he's
selling this girl on a site to regular
people and just because there's a check
and that person's getting an STD test
it's justifiable and now she's doing
that
and it is that common too that this is
this is normal across the board like
anyone that becomes popular in any
capacity this is what happens
um and then the phone stops ringing as
the popularity dissipates right and then
eventually they feature dance so feature
dancing is at a strip club you would if
someone would have some kind of name
there would be some novelty around them
which would bring people in and they'd
pay them a fee on top of whatever tips
they would get but that's like bottom of
the barrel that's like them like holding
on for dear life but eventually
the phone stops ringing
and they've been told for five years
what's crazy so girls start to age out
of the industry around 30.
so the but these girls they've been told
for five years this is who you are you
can't do anything else no one else is
going to want you you're gonna have to
continue to compromise
so that you can become relevant again
right once all the compromise is gone
you're left with this this the scary
thing because if you believe a lie to be
true it's true to you
so this girl believes my worth
is indicative of me selling myself for
sex there's nothing else that I can ever
do no man's ever going to want to marry
me there's no organization that's ever
going to want me to contribute to it
because I'm worthless I'm dirty I'm
damaged goods this stuff's always going
to be on the internet
and they choose to medicate or
they just take their lives so 30 people
that I was in the industry with
that's their story mostly women or like
28 of those women
man
and that's just people that I was close
to the number is far greater and it's
not just overdose and suicide it's it's
people putting themselves in situations
where you know it's it's really like
it's not I hate to say it it's
interesting but it's insane to think
about how many girls end up in
relationships where the abuse is great
enough where they're murdered because
you put yourself in situations that you
would never put yourself in because you
devalue yourself right it's like I I
deserve this because I'm you know
whatever and you just live your life
like that and then even like all of my
roommates that I had when I was in the
industry dead
but it's because they they live their
life in such a way where they didn't
care if they lived you know like
something like one guy fell off a
balcony he was drunk in Mexico and fell
off a balcony like he would have never
done that in what's so sad is when they
releases obituary it says is stage name
and how many porn movies he did in on X
Y and Z and doesn't even talk about the
man that he was right that's your
Epitaph right if that's what you're
known for that's that's your epitaph
one of the big criticisms of the porn
industry that you hear especially from
feminists is that it's dominated by
these male producers who are taking all
the money and they're being financially
and professionally abusive of the women
to say nothing of the physical abuse
but then the pro-porn people will say
okay then the the porn performers can
just go on to only fans or
presumably they're a copycat websites
out there where you the performer has
control over the production and they're
keeping more of the money or or whatever
and this is exploded even though I think
the vast majority of the women on only
fans don't make any money really at all
yeah so it's I mean it's pretty sad so
it's like it's so what's happening
across the board especially any of the
girls from the porn industry or any most
of the girls that have any kind of
notoriety it's catfishing 2.0 so what's
happening is is curated content so it's
it's you know fill it's it's videos and
photographs that were shot prior to and
then you got you know Joe Blow sitting
in a basement having a conversation with
these people because so on only fans you
can chat well I guess not so you can it
seems like you're chatting with a person
well here it is every single time you
you message someone you have to pay for
that message every time you get a video
you have to pay for that video so you
it's a subscription base so the
subscription to to that person might be
a dollar or twenty dollars but the money
is made in the DMS and on the DMS you
have to pay per message and you have to
pay per video but the messaging and the
pictures and the video it's getting sent
to you by a person that's just pulling
stock footage that already exists and
you believe that you're having a
conversation in real time with someone
and you're paying for every response and
it's just someone sitting in a basement
somewhere it's probably some dude yes
right yeah oh man that's awesome that's
why I'm saying it's catfishing two
points oh man that is so that makes a
thing that it would be sad and degrading
even if it were this porn actress sure
personally but it is so much worse
but then
if you're the guy
and you're you're not gonna meet this
girl you're not going to marry this girl
you're not gonna
if if your only interaction is just
these videos and these messages
does it even matter sure does it I don't
know you're just writing these messages
does it matter that some fat guy in a
basement rather than some like cute porn
lady well because in because your
emotions are real and you're you're
forming an emotional connection with
this person
and in in your in your telling your your
brain your mind your heart it's okay
with me buying intimacy
so I'm going to believe that's a okay
and B I'm probably going to distance
myself from any opportunity of engaging
in reality because there's an
opportunity for me to be rejected
there's you know there's a lot of
there's a lot of risk involved
and so but what if this becomes my
expectations and nothing can meet my
expectations because my expectations are
built on something that's not real
because they used to have the old phone
sex lines sure in the 90s it was you
dial 1 900 number yeah but you believe
even then we'll be talking to this sexy
girl you're probably not right you're
probably not right you know if you're if
you're working the hotlines you're yeah
you're not working in front of the game
not some smoking hot girl sitting here
at two in the morning on your phone
you're just not yeah like all of that
stuff is built on creating a reality
this fictitious that's why it's scalable
it's scalable because it's not real
and end the opportunity cost that you
point out
you you can't be messaging
this illusion of this hot chick who's
really probably a fat dude every night
and simultaneously be pursuing a healthy
romantic relationship that might lead to
marriage you can't if you do one you
can't do the other but you're also
disconnecting yourself from reality yeah
because what happens it like compromise
in any area of your life will lead to
compromise in every area of your life
right so it will impact your integrity
it'll impact like if if I believe
relationships are built on transaction
Michael the the moment that you can't do
something for me and you text me and you
need to have a conversation with me or
you want me to help you move a couch man
you haven't done anything for me lately
why am I going to respond to you why am
I going to answer your phone call
because I had this transactionary
mindset right and that could bleed into
your family well absolutely anything
well I'm not going to value your
relationship I'm not going to Value
quality time yeah I'm not going to Value
you know a multitude of things because
I'm disconnected from what's real what
about for the girls though so I I see
how awful this is for the consumers yeah
and for everyone who's around the
consumers yeah but these girls yeah so
let's say there was one girl who made
headlines because she sold her bath
water yeah and made like a zillion
dollars doing it or something yeah okay
that's the headline you saw I made a
bazillion dollars or some stupid thing
on only fans
but then you look at the statistics the
vast majority of these women are making
nothing yeah and and you think of again
talk about opportunity cost the moment
that you put one picture of yourself up
the moment you present yourself as a
porn girl on the internet yeah
that changes the trajectory of your life
what also you can't do something like
that you can't compromise your dignity
yeah without a belief that knowing it's
going to cost you something yeah like if
if I was looking at porn in a library or
wherever you know in a coffee shop
whatever wherever wherever even even if
I was looking at something on Instagram
that was slightly inappropriate if
someone walks past me
yeah of course or you know I get rid of
it why there's a deep level of Shame
and there's there's just something about
sexuality there's something about that
that is ingrained in you so deeply that
you can't deny it yeah and when you
start to deny the things that are true
that you cannot run from it's going to
cost you more than you would ever want
to pay and I know that person right it's
so evil it's just so powerfully evil and
I know it's a fallen world and there's
lots of evil to go around but it seems
so particularly evil
oh and did you did you get a glimpse of
what the top of the industry looks like
meaning beyond the casting directors
Beyond even the distributors or whatever
it how conscious are the people who run
this of how they're not conscious of
that I mean I mean how aware are they of
how yeah I mean they're they're just not
well they're aware of how much money
they're making yeah so I mean so you
have mind geek that's the organization
out of Canada that owns Mo you know
they've monopolized the porn industry
and they do that that's the one that
owns Pornhub Pornhub and many others
many many others okay like you you if if
it's something that someone could recall
they own it wow
um and in addition to that they own
traffic junkie so traffic junkie is when
you go to a porn site it actually it
captures your information and sells it
to Facebook and Google
so when you are on Facebook and you've
been watching porn earlier that day or
that night before and you see that
inappropriate thing pop up on your
Facebook feed it's an advertisement it's
not an accident my friend wow it's the
very evidence that someone's been
shelling your information so it's funny
because if
if fear of the just punishments of our
Lord and God is not enough to keep
people from doing bad things because
people mess up and they do bad things
all the time
uh the just punishments uh or the unjust
punishments maybe of these website
cookie trafficking companies that that
might put a little fear into people too
so and the so the company this type of
company that exists is owned by the porn
distributor the biggest foreign
by mindgeek which owns PornHub many
other organizations but the but the
scary thing is so the porn industry just
eclipsed a hundred billion dollar
industry
a hundred billion dollars so if you take
the NFL Major League Baseball and the
NBA and put all the revenue together it
still doesn't Eclipse how much money
porn makes if you take how many people
visit Netflix Amazon and Twitter on a
daily basis it doesn't Eclipse how many
people are watching porn on a daily
basis in the neighborhood of 30 to 35
percent of all the data transferred on
the internet on a daily basis is some
type of pornography but you're telling
me that the people who run this
extremely rich powerful industry who see
the data maybe they don't meet the
performers but they at least absolutely
they're completely detached from really
human interaction because because the
the way that porn makes money is
monetized through viewership just the
same way like you like YouTube's
monetized right YouTube got that model
from PornHub like all the major uh
technological advancements that you see
that are happening
they're taking the model that came from
porn I had an academic buddy of mine
once told me that porn sets a lot of the
technological advancements yeah of these
products sure including when you're on
YouTube and you skip ahead and a
thumbnail pops up and it's yeah here's
the part of the video my friend was
telling me this comes from porn because
people want you know they have short
attention spans and so they want to jump
ahead so
so I guess that people say that to give
credit to the porn industry they say
look they're moving the technology
forward and even so the way that like
you know the way that you become
monetized and make money off of YouTube
or any other social media is you get to
the point where there's enough
viewership where you can run ads on your
media right that came from porn wow the
thing that's so hard for me to believe
though is just that the these people at
the maybe it's easy to believe but it's
people at the top they're just so
divorced they're just looking at numbers
on spreadsheets they really don't see
the human connection if if I were
running an industry and one of my top
workers
came out and said hey 30 of my friends
killed themselves in the last decade
yeah because of this industry like it
would be hard for me running the
industry not to
notice that right but they do notice it
you know what they do someone takes
their life so there's there's a specific
example of this I won't use the name
um but there was a girl that
um she she didn't want to work with a
specific male performer this performer
had done like some like homosexual porn
Okay and she chose like I don't want to
work with this person and then she was
attacked on social media because she
didn't want to work with this person for
being homophobic right and then so so
now she's being attacked to the point
where
she ends up taking her own life she
hangs herself in a public park
this happened like 2016 2017. and and
then so what the industry does and has
done so this is their playbook someone
dies
and then they make a best of
film to honor her but they monopolize
off of this tragedy so not only do they
see it they make more money right they
figure out how to capitalize on it sure
but but to them it's just a product well
people are products yeah people are
products and sex is transactional across
the board that's why there's there's so
much Detachment right and so and that's
the danger for the consumer as well
say more about that well the danger for
the consumer so if I am watching
pornography I'm forming this
relationship with a screen in my hand
and I'm detaching myself from reality
I'm becoming disconnected from what
intimacy actually is I'm re-ingraining
this you know this neurological pattern
where I can be selfish I I I'm not going
to be rejected
um sex is transactional it's about me
when I want it uh and it just it just
just reintegrates this behavior in
myself where it's nothing like being in
an actual relationship with a human
being whatsoever
now you as the performer
are you seeing this happen to you that
you're just not viewing people as people
you're becoming dehumanized or no I
would say yes but it first happens with
you
you detach yourself from reality because
number one you're going by pseudonym you
don't even go by your real name so it's
interesting that the first thing that
the director promised me is I can make
your name famous but the first thing
that happened was my name actually died
because if I can detach you from any
kind of you know
belief in you know there's some kind of
moral you know aspect of this that I
should or shouldn't be doing if I'm
calling myself by another name
then it detaches you from it because and
it covers the shame you Joshua Broome
have a mother you have a God you have an
upbringing you have a moral sense yeah
at least some kind of moral sense that
you but you whatever your performer name
is right well that guy just he just got
invented five minutes ago right that
kind of anything yeah it's like the
Tropic Thunder it's like I'm a dude
playing a dude disguises another dude
that doesn't even know what duty is you
know but it's true though it's that you
because you're you're you have a stage
name and everyone around you caused my
stage name in and that for me that that
became real in that I had people in my
life saying hey I love you
what are you doing yeah like you could
be doing other stuff
why are you doing this
and then you hear that and you're like
well either I have to take into
consideration what they said or I push
them away
and I pushed anyone that was speaking
sensibly to me away and I just
surrounded myself with a bunch of people
who were patting me on my back on my way
to hell
wow
so
how long into the industry before you
start to think
I've pushed away all these people that I
love and I'm not happy and I
how how long is that time period yeah so
for me
um I think like to revisit a question
you asked earlier he said can you make
money in this industry for me I you know
someone who I grew up not having a
father in my home yet the father
um he was in the same town grew up in a
very small town in South Carolina and
the added Dynamic was I saw him I knew
he was my father but he was never a
father in my home or my life did he
acknowledge that you were his son uh yes
but but that but that was it there was
no there was like a few attempts and
um
yeah so there was a few attempts for him
to to be part of my life in some
capacity but he ended up getting married
and then you know you know he was they
were both 16 at the time and my mom
chose to keep me and he chose to you
know continue living his life
and I would see him
and that made me feel what's wrong with
me yeah but like it was confusing at
first and then it made me angry
specifically because I saw this man in
this healthy Dynamic like he like he was
married and they had kids and they had a
nice home and you know they had all
these things and it was just me and my
mom struggling wow most people who grew
up without a father I mean what do I
know I just I guess in my imagination of
this the father is on the other side of
the world before it was just not there I
imagine it's much much harder if you see
this guy and you see his new family yeah
I mean there's there's definitely
different aspects of fatherlessness
where it's like some if someone in my
case or like there's a there's there's
various you know traumas that come with
levels of fatherlessness like divorce or
maybe some a father that's in the home
but he's not present but there's but yes
to your point it was very frustrating
that the thing that I felt like I needed
most and the thing that I wanted most
was in Arm's Reach but had no interest
in me were you aware of this at the time
or you were just angry and you didn't
know why well I I was confused until I
was angry but I was always aware
you know because he was there right you
know so that caused so me having a high
achiever personality it's like well I
can outwork
my feeling of lack I can overcome my
feeling of worthlessness or my need to
be valuable so through affirmation it
was you know first it was Scholastics
then it was Sports then it was getting
the girl that no one else could get
thinking the most girls and so on and so
on but being in that industry that
personality trait came with me both me
feeling inadequate and me feeling like I
need to prove myself right so being
someone who's someone analytical I love
statistics and it's like okay just I'm
tracking literally on a spreadsheet once
I make a million dollars then I'll be
happy I'll be fulfilled it's like so I'm
like tracking it like it's some kind of
game I do it I make a million dollars
and guess what it didn't work and then
the same thing like in the industry I
got nominated for uh performer of the
Year got nominated three years in a row
didn't win didn't win didn't win fourth
year I won it and I thought like that
was like the Mount Rushmore of porn
because it was this big award show and
then it was not only the the actors and
the actresses but the you know the
organizations the studios like they
voted on it so they meant like you're
the guy
and I won and when I won I thought that
it would bring me the sense of relief
this this this feeling of lack this
frustration this pain I thought I would
experience joy and fulfillment and I did
for a second
and but it didn't work it didn't last
and that quickly Amplified my anxiety
deep in my depression it took me to a
place where decision after decision
after decision led me to a I okay I'm
now making a plan to take my life
so at that point you are truly the dog
who catches the car there is nowhere
else for you to go yeah you've made a
lot of money you're the number one guy
there isn't there is no achievement to
get right in this line of work right
I never got into video games except for
a little period of time yeah when I was
like five years old I played Donkey Kong
and then when I was a teenager I got a
kick out of Grand Theft Auto oh yeah
because it was so crazy it was so you
know you just keep running people over
and yeah flying helicopters into
buildings doing all this crazy stuff
yeah and
I remember though playing the video game
in this aimless way not on the missions
just aimlessly shooting people or
whatever robbing things yeah
and after a certain point
I realized this was pointless
and I just go kill myself in the game
and I've fought back on that at some
point over the years
and I think there's something profound
in that
intuition that if you're you're aimless
and you're just doing things for
pleasure and then you reach what would
appear to be the maximum amount of
pleasure
I've never
considered ending my life right
but I think intellectually I could see
how someone could get to that place yeah
and you get to that place yeah
yeah I literally got to a place where so
I it's interesting so I just came from
uh I was doing a speaking engagement in
Atlanta and
um it was the first time I've been back
to Atlanta since the last time I left
Atlanta the last time I left Atlanta was
11 years ago and that's what I had done
my last film you did the a porn film in
Atlanta in Atlanta okay 11 years ago
and then I'm flying back to LAX and in
my head I'm like making the decision
like okay I'm going to take my life when
I get home go home I get enough I do
some some research I'm saying how much
you know these pain medications like
what I have to take to overdose
I get it I line them up on the counter
I'm like okay I can't swallow this many
pills at once but so this and then I've
got this check in my pocket and it's
just like it's just driving me crazy
it's this giant like cashier's check I
just feel it in my pocket I'm wearing
slacks and I just feel it against my
skin it's driving me crazy I'm not sure
why I'm so aware of it and then I take
it out and I start thinking like well if
I'm going to do this
um you know I assume my bank account
will go to my mom or my brother or
something like that so I'll go deposit
this check and then I'll come back and
take care of this and I welcome to this
bank and normally I would just go to the
Dropbox or the ATM because on the memo
of the check it said what was for like
it would have the title the movie which
was always grotesque and I was
humiliated I didn't want to look someone
in the eye and say hey here's the check
for me selling myself for seconds didn't
want to do that but today on on this day
I didn't care I was like whatever I
don't care I went through the line you
know signed the check slide slide the
check across the counter normal
transaction and I pivot to walk away and
she kind of stops me and she says excuse
me Joshua
are you okay
Joshua can I do something for you
and what she didn't know is it had been
over a year since I had heard my name
I'd stop answering my mom's text I'd
gotten rid of like I've unfriended
anyone that followed me on social media
that was like from my actual life my
fraternity Brothers my friends from high
school my brother I wasn't returning any
tax I wasn't returning any calls the
only person that it existed was my stage
name which everyone on set called me
everyone knew me I was very well known
so the gym that I went to the barber
shop that I went to like everywhere that
I went that's all that I heard Joshua
did not exist but when she said my name
it stopped me in my tracks and it
wrecked me
because all of a sudden I was faced with
what was real
because at that moment I'd created this
plausible reality based on lies guilt
and shame
up to and including if the stage name
guy kills himself well who cares he's
just he's not real yeah but if Joshua
kills himself yeah Joshua was a kid
Joshua has a mom yeah Joshua is pissed
off at his dad Joshua has a brother yeah
so for me I like what I felt immediately
was guilt and regret from not letting my
mom know if I was okay like that was the
last few text messages that she sent me
she's like you know dang it just tell me
if you're okay or not like if you're not
going to come home if you're going to
stay doing them whatever you're doing
whatever I just want to know if you're
okay and I was so selfish
and so caught up in my shame and my
pride that I couldn't even pick up the
phone or send a text and let my mom know
that I was alive
and in that moment when I heard my name
that my mom had given me
my reality was challenged and I felt the
pain that I was numb to
so I ran home and I called my mom
and then my mom said what she had been
saying for you know I'd been in La for
eight nine years something like that but
I was in the industry for six and she
said the same thing she had said I love
you
you're better than this
please come home
so I did so that day I called my agent I
called my PR person quit I quit I quit
I'm out of here I even like found
someone to sublease my place I'm like I
don't care you know just pay rent you
can have literally have everything in my
home like all my furniture everything
I'm gonna take some clothes
and I'm I'm out of here there's this odd
paradox
on the one hand you're behaving in this
extremely selfish way on the other hand
you've completely
neglected yourself and denied the
existence of yourself yeah
I say it's a paradox because I don't
think it's it's exactly a contradiction
or an impossibility in fact very often
that would appear to be how these things
go killing yourself is both extremely
selfish and a complete rejection of the
self how does
how is that yeah it it's it's an
interesting thing to struggle with
because on the outside aesthetically you
know I was taking very good care of
myself but I was dying inside I think
you know that's that's why it's so much
easier to put on a mask you pretend you
know for me I just wanted the person in
front of me to like me or to do the
thing to get the affirmation I didn't
care about anything else
but I was a dissolution and disconnected
from reality the power of the name is so
striking yeah because we think oh who
cares about a name you can have a
nickname you can change your name it's
no big deal that's just words words
words we call you know I call this a
glass but I could call this a
parakeet wouldn't right it's just
whatever it's just whatever it is
but that isn't true names do matter
quite a lot yeah the first charge given
to Adam in the Garden of Eden is name
everything yeah all the way up to modern
day this big political fight that
everybody seems to be in right now over
transgenderism right is basically a
fight over names yeah and the
relationship between names and reality
if you call me
Johnny or you call me Mary Sue it's not
gonna if you call me Rachel maddowell
I'll probably laugh
but if you say that to someone
who is in the transgender movement sure
the person will lose it if you
mispronounce or misgender meaning use
the correct pronouns for somebody this
is the worst crime you can possibly
commit against them because they know
the power of a name I mean even the the
transgender transition
is a kind of ritual suicide right where
you say okay my old self that's my dead
name that's a dead person I forget that
person yeah I'm this new person
it's hard not to see a parallel to what
you're describing in the industry sure
sure and and that and I think in in a
deeper way in any aspect it's like it's
an identity crisis yeah if my identity
is rooted in a belief around a feeling
or a behavior and I identify myself
based on that yeah I'm going to
constantly be in this identity crisis
because there's actually an author of
life that's given me an identity that I
I don't get to choose
who or what I am
but I can feel a certain way but my
feelings can't Define me
because I've already been defined by an
author
I I was talking to a Exorcist on this
show actually
and we were talking about selling your
soul to the devil and he said well you
know you can't actually do that right
that's what do you mean you can't do
that he says you don't own your soul
yeah it's not yours you know you didn't
make your own life you didn't con you
didn't craft your soul and so you can't
sell it either the devil tricks you
makes you think you can salvage you
actually can't sell it you you can't
totally Define yourself we tried to do
that a lot sure but you can't you didn't
choose how you came into this world you
damn well sure shouldn't choose how you
go out of the world right and so you
have obligations to other people and so
this bank teller
providentially yeah calls out says your
name yeah this hits you you call your
actual mother not your invented personas
right yeah I call my mom and then and
then I run home and uh and then I spend
two years
just doing everything I can to cover up
what I'd done like I literally I had
tattoos cover them up with new tattoos
you know shaved my head deleted my
social media did everything that I could
to hide what I'd done like like very
like genesis 2 Genesis 3. yeah I'm
running I'm hiding I don't want to be
found and
um
I get to a place where
I just I'm okay like I look like I'm
okay on the outside I start working at a
gym and again that the personality
trait's still there it's like what like
that's just who I am like regardless of
what I'm doing if I'm eating wings I'm
gonna eat the most or the hottest like
I'm gonna win I'm gonna die to win no
matter what it's just who I am so it's
like okay if I'm gonna be a personal
trainer I'm going to be the best thing
personal trainer there's ever been yeah
and I've quickly worked my way up in
this gym and you know worked my way into
management and I'm doing okay
but at night I'm not doing okay because
the reality of what's on the internet
and people recognizing me and me just
wanting to be a regular person was
nearly impossible but I was almost in
denial of that I consider myself a
fairly Mimi guy like I'm fairly
internety I'm not very plugged into pop
culture but internet AI I have a large
collection of memes yeah and one of my
producers I will not say which one
embarrass this producer said are you
aware of this meme of Joshua and I said
I'm not and he said it's it's this funny
meme it's from a porn scene yeah it
became it took on a life of its own yeah
so it's you
it's you in a bathtub and someone comes
in and says hey you're at the beach and
you need a lifeguard or something you
say I'm not in a beach I'm in a bathroom
or something yeah yeah so
um to
so there there was this Meme and it's
been shared probably I think it's been
shared over 100 million times it became
really popular on me uh on Vine and then
it became really popular on Tick Tock
but there's this scene where this goes
to the ridiculous of the writing yeah
happens in pornography but
um I'm in a bathtub and then a lifeguard
runs in yeah and she's like get out
there's a shark in the water
and I was like
what are you talking about lady like
this is a beach it's not a you know this
is the this is not a beach yeah yeah
that's so that's what I say this is not
a beach it's a bathtub and but with it
with like
like straight face you know you know
it's funny it is is it it's a very funny
but in that it's
maybe maybe a lot of porn is like this
but it that strikes me as it's so
self-aware about what it is there's no
there's no real pretense it's just like
haha we're here right yeah I mean she
like she ran in with like the little
like lifeguard thing and she's wearing
like she's dressed in like like Baywatch
you know she's got the red bathing suit
on you know and she comes in I'm just
sitting in the bathtub and that's and
that's the meme it's like this isn't a
beach it's a bathtub like is the meme so
if this went viral during the years of
Vine
were you out of the industry at this
point or were you still in it Vine was
like 2012-ish yeah so I got out at in
2012. this is right around the time yeah
so it went it went viral then and then
it went and then people started like
remaking it on YouTube and then it got
popular on Tick Tock as well
um and then I found out about Tick Tock
and I was like and I oh so through
finding out like how like popular Tick
Tock was being I take I took a peek at
Tick Tock and I'm like oh this is not
for me you know this is bad this is bad
news yeah so you think regular social
media is bad tick tock is just cracked
because there's no home screen right you
just always in some video with music and
then but then I then I talked with
someone and it was like well there's um
there's your your for you page and then
there's a page where it's just the
people you follow yeah I was like
anyway
they're like well you know they're
showing me data it's like how many you
know this is the most downloaded app you
know in this age demographic and so on
and I started thinking like well okay
you know my objective is to reach people
with the gospel so how could how could I
leverage this for that I'm like let's
let's think about this and then I start
doing some research and then someone
sent me like hey have you seen this meme
or like something about the meme and I
was like I have no idea you know because
it became popular like after I was out
of the industry so I have no idea about
it and I I did some research and I was
like man like 100 million views like 100
million times this thing has been shared
it's like as far as like popularity of
memes it was like top 20 it was like you
know it was when one at one point it was
like one of the most popular means that
existed and
um I was like this is this is ridiculous
and then I made a tick tock around it
and it was like but it was like uh who I
who I used to be and who I am today and
it was just and it was just like a back
and forth of like it was that picture
and then like me getting baptized and
then like that a picture of me in the
industry and then me getting married and
a picture of me in the industry
um and then you know me like you know in
my family yeah and then you know it
reached you know so so I've been sharing
like not just with the moon but just
like sharing my testimony
and uh so just I I shared something
along that lines on Instagram uh about a
month ago and it reached seven million
people
but the organization that we put
together so it's one thing to reach a
lot of people so we've got an ecosystem
where there's you know using AI yeah uh
there there's there's key words that if
you type
you'll get a message and that message
routes you to an opportunity to you know
like biblical literacy or like talk to a
person or if you're struggling with
pornography there's there's a website
that we've created that there's a 10
steps of how to be free from it and so
it took that it's great to reach
millions of people but we took that and
and create a systemized way of
connecting people all those people to
The Next Step whether it be like freedom
from pornography or hearing the gospel
or being connected to a church or
whatever what's it like to be recognized
in porn I have a very moderate slight
public profile
and so every now and again someone will
come up and say hey buddy you know I
loved your commentary on something sure
or at some labor wants to throw an egg
at me but it's it's always
people are open if they see me right but
with porn yeah people don't want to
admit that they're watching it so do
they come up to you and or when I was in
the industry
unapologetically but well I guess
I think you have to factor in the fact
that like I was in Hollywood I was
living in Hollywood or I was in Vegas
those are the places I was I was at the
most right so
unapologetically people would come up
and ask you know to for autographs or to
take pictures with me well
um it was a very common occurrence it
wasn't just you know someone across the
room like looks away well that happens
more often now than not not a ton but
like wow yeah but so you're you are
being recognized regularly even now that
you're back in your old town with your
mother well because from the outside
looking in like a month removed from
being the most famous person in that
industry
so in in just the way that content comes
out you know it's it's not it doesn't
come out you know I I film a film yeah I
mean there's stuff steadily coming out a
year after I'm I'm out of the industry
so people are like what do you aren't
you that guy like what what are you
doing here why are you working at a gym
like what are you what are you doing in
this what are you doing in in North
Carolina like what are you doing wow
um so it happened so often I would just
lie until I got found out and then I had
done over a thousand films so I was one
Google search away from you know
everyone knowing everything I didn't
want to know right
um so did they connect your real name
with your stage name was that a common
thing well it was like on on IMDb it was
it was connected okay
um so and and like unfortunately like
all the things that I had done that I
was proud of were on there but it got
buried yeah
Avalanche before yeah
um but yeah so people would find you
know I would I would lie until I got
found out and then I would just deal
with it
um hurt a lot of people
um almost got fired from different
things
um people didn't want me to personal
train them but I just continued chipping
away and then it just kind of became
normal it was like okay I'm this trainer
that's operating in a high capacity I'm
a decent leader in the gym
um so there's this stuff about them but
you know whatever
and it just becomes kind of normal and
then there's this girl that starts
coming to the gym super gorgeous and I
asked her out on a date and she says no
which I was like excuse me yeah I'm a
good looking guy personal trainer yeah
yeah I got a million bucks yeah
um but she says no and um and then she's
like well uh we we can go on a run if
you want and I'm like all right you know
I I'll I'll run with you you know I
don't really love like doing long runs
like you would have like a 5K and I'm
like but for you yes 100 I will run and
I go there to meet her and I'm waiting
on her to get there and I almost feel
like my mom's voice in my head saying
don't you dare lie to her don't you hurt
her yeah because I'd hurt girl after
girl after girl after girl how so just
by being I would I would I would not
tell him about my past and then all of a
sudden yeah yeah yeah
um and it was you know sometimes you
know withholding the truth is just as
painful as not telling the truth at all
um so but for her I'm waiting and like
I'm feeling like don't you lie to her
and she gets there and we we never made
it to a run we continued walking and I
just look at her I'm like hey
I want to tell you something I did a
little bit of porn she was like excuse
me come again can you say that one more
time and then I was just like
tell the whole truth you know just like
man up tell the truth and then like you
know I blacked out like five minutes
just like you know did all this stuff
and you know when I was you know just
literally at any bad thing that I could
recall just like spitting it out and
then she's like pretty shocked
and then after a moment of obviously
processing this Insanity it ends with
like I stole a chocolate bar when I was
eight years old like I kicked my brother
in the shin and I said it was someone
else
um but she looks at me she says uh well
here's the deal
the worst thing you've ever done
doesn't Define you and the greatest
thing you'll ever do that doesn't Define
you either
you don't get to Define yourself God
defines you do you know who God is and
for me I was used to putting on I call
it the first date mask I don't know who
I am but I'm going to become whoever you
want me to be so I started regurgitating
whatever I knew like cosmological
argument like yes like blah blah blah
blah blah and she asked me deeper
questions that were simplistic but very
foreign to me you know are you plugged
into a community anywhere are you
attending church regularly what's your
relationship with Jesus like and I was
like
whatever you're talking about I don't
think I got that and she's like well
I've been a Christian since I was in
seventh grade my family's Christian I'm
not perfect by any means but my
relationship with Jesus is the
foundation in which I live my life
so what kind of food do you like it's
like
what I just told you the truth and you
didn't reject me I've been lying to
people my whole life because I thought
if anyone knew anything about me the
person that his own father rejected yeah
why would you want to know integral
details about me
and she was like yeah well you know what
are what are some of your hopes dreams
like what do you want to accomplish
I didn't have any answers I didn't I
didn't have the capacity to dream right
and we just walk and talk and then the
next weekend so this this was a
um this is actually Easter eight years
ago
and then um this was the Easter you went
on the walk oh man you know sometimes
yeah symbolism's a little on the note
yes yeah and uh and then the next week
she invites me to church
and I go and I'm sitting in this church
and when I walk in uh there's this uh
this wooden signage and it says we want
to help people we want to love people
where they are
and encourage them to grow in their
relationship with Jesus Christ
I was like
sounds good but if you knew anything
about me
no way
um and then this pastor gets up and it's
this guy that reminds me of my
grandfather and like for me I the little
bit of church that I had experienced was
like very
um Southern Baptist like like but not
like in in no way good uh where all I
remembered was if you had a wrinkle or
in your shirt or a tattoo on your arm
you're going to hell yeah that is the
unforgivable sin yeah Wrinkle in your
shirt yeah I mean that's that's that's
what I remembered and yet this guy gets
up here and he's you know dressed
somewhat casually and then he starts
talking about this dynamic between
Jonathan and David and when David died
he's talking he's talking about how
historically the previous kingdom was
completely wiped out because they didn't
want the previous Kingdom to think they
had any access to the New Kingdom and
David was different he actually asked
hey is there anyone left out of
Jonathan's lineage in my fable Chef was
still alive in my fellowship new history
so he was expecting death
and and instead David brought him into
his kingdom and restored his land and
then he he keeps talking he talks about
well Romans 3 23 says that we've all
sinned and fall short of the glory of
God so who's guilty of sin everyone yeah
and then Romans 6 23 says the wage of
sin is death
so each and every person because of
their sin they're separated from a holy
and perfect God there's a bridge that
you need to get to God that you don't
have access to because you're imperfect
and he goes on to talk about how Jesus
fully God fully man came into this world
and lived a life that we could never
live
he bridged the Gap died on the cross
paid for all sin for all time
it's through faith in him it changes
everything
and and for me it what it did was it
contended with how I saw myself and how
I saw God
because I was like there's no way that I
could have access to God because I'm not
good then wrestling with no one's good
it's an amazing feeling Catholics have
sacramental confession yeah where we go
in and we confess our sins to Christ
right and the priest is acting in in
Persona Christie yeah and
some weeks are worse than others yeah
some weeks are a little lighter than
others but what's amazing is even
understanding all of that even
understanding that we're all we all sin
and Foster the glory of God even growing
in sanctity even growing in virtue which
can and does happen yeah when you're
standing in line yeah to confess your
sins it's that same feeling you're
describing well no that thing that I did
that's a bridge too far there's no way
and then you go and you confess your
sins in the priest says okay you know
yeah Agate absolvo yeah you know okay
three Hail Marys get out of here see you
yeah a couple weeks and you can know it
uh intellectually but you can still you
still feel that somehow there's no that
thing that I did there's no way yeah
so for for me in that moment I I
surrendered and submitted to the fact
that
I could not fix myself and there was a
God that loved me so much that he sent
his son into this world to suffer and
die
so that he could bridge the gap that I
could never bridge and something
happened in my heart for me I I
surrendered my life and I and I let go
of the burden that I've been carrying
and the relationship with the father
that I always desired
I realized I had
through Christ you know and so so that
happened that week after
and
um so two things happened so number one
um this this girl her name's hope and
she's been you know her name's hope and
she's been my wife for seven years oh
man and we've got three kids and
um the the other thing that happened was
amazing so I I hear this and then I go
into this church and I'm like hey uh can
I share this with someone so I sit down
with a pastor and I share with him my
story and then he connects me to another
pastor and this pastor is like okay I
want to get a Bible in your hand here's
how you read the Bible here's you know
just a little bit of observation
interpretation application like here's
how you read the Bible in proper context
and I just fall in love with the Bible
and I just can't get enough of it I
actually start asking off of work and
I'm like giving away you know personal
training clients and I'm spending 15 to
20 hours a week with this man at this
church and he's discipling me and I just
fall in love with the Bible to the point
where I end up going to Bible College I
go to Liberty and you know study
Christian Ministries and focus on
biblical Theology and in the process I I
start sharing my testimony
and I I feel like okay in in the early
stages as I'm not preaching I'm just
sharing my testimony but as I'm up there
it's like I felt this need to perform
you know it's like for me like I was a
theater guy before I was you know the
porn guy and it was like for me you know
I needed to emote emotion I need to you
know I want people to cry I want people
to laugh you know I wanted to create
this experience for someone based on
what I was you know portraying and I I
wrote something you know I took my story
and made it you know something that I
wanted to present and I get up there and
I just feel this anxiety and for me it
you don't live the life that I've lived
and yeah like you're pretty comfortable
in your own right yeah yeah I mean just
like there's nothing that I'm ever gonna
do where I'm like I'm you know there's
cameras there's lights there's a stage
there's x amount of people whatever
um but for me it's like I I love those
situations actually but in this moment I
felt so much anxiety
and I couldn't put my finger on it and I
felt this like man I gotta do a good job
I've got to do a good job so that I will
be liked and I'd reverted back to that
mindset where like I had to prove myself
I was still the kid that his father
didn't want
because sometimes you'll carry you know
this
um uh I forget the surgery but that
yours you know if you have this Cataract
and you have it removed if you have it
for a long time even if it's removed and
you completely see through the lens that
your mind can trick you into believing
that it is still your vision's still
cloudy even though it's not
so I've been walking with this emotional
limp for so long that even though I had
been freed from it I'd practice walking
with it so much it's muscle memory sure
right yeah and I step up to the I I step
from the stage I was like from backstage
to the podium but when I stepped onto
the podium
I just felt this like overwhelming sense
where not audibly but like I heard in my
mind in my spirit
I love you
son I love you
and I and I was like okay I don't need
to perform and I essentially I took what
I wrote I turned it over and I spent
five minutes
sharing my testimony and I spent the
rest of the time trying my best to walk
people through
what Romans have to say what the book of
Romans has to say about salvation you
know this is why in the traditional
liturgy the
it's chanted yeah one of the reasons for
the chant people think it's it's to be
really theatrical smells and bells you
know the traditional Latin mess it's not
it's it's really the opposite because
when the gospel is chanted yeah
the preacher yeah takes his personality
out of it and it's just the word yeah
he's pronouncing it in this way that is
quite beautiful but it's it's without
the you know and here's the moment when
I'm gonna really put a lot of Gusto into
it yeah I had a priest in New York very
good friend of mine who said that some
of these priests and preachers who make
it a Big Show and a performance they
they tell jokes like ham actors in a
dying Vaudeville play yeah and what they
ought to do is limit their repertoire to
the jokes that Saint John told the
Blessed motherweller son bled on the
cross yeah it's a very intense way of
saying it yeah but I think it's a good
message you know yeah you're
you're talking about
the Son of God yeah God himself the
second person of the Trinity comes down
takes on flesh dwells Among Us suffers
in his passion is crucified to redeem
mankind it's not there for you to go do
a soft shoe and Shuffle off to Buffalo
right 100 and you're right and you feel
this ease the moment that you actually
get up there you say oh I don't need to
I can take the tap shoes off yeah I mean
100 I mean I I think there's much to be
taken from and learned from Catholicism
in in regards to Protestant like
practice where like the Liturgy is
beautiful and the story like history
like church history is beautiful and I
think
um removing yourself from that it takes
away from what it actually is well I
love that just even your experience of
it I'm glad that it didn't affect your
uh testimony ultimately but even that
feeling of
your muscle memory yeah you know it
in modernity we we think of virtue and
vice as just oh I did this thing but it
doesn't matter so okay I look at porn
every single night and I go further and
further into these kinds of fantasies
but that's not going to affect my real
life that's just a thing that I do at
night but we're creatures of habit Vice
and virtue are habits so yeah you just
do something all the time yeah well just
neurologically that the data says much
different you know it's like I love
there's a lot of data around
um just like your your brain your heart
in the way that you interact in the
world and uh so like for example a few
days ago on social media I just posted
like a a 60-second clip of me saying is
is masturbation sin yes and here and
here's what masturbation is and here's
what First Corinthians says about love
compare and contrast the two and tell me
where it lines up yeah you know
um and it goes viral because you know
some people are agreeing but most people
are disagreeing and what happens is is
when you're confronted with conviction
yeah
you don't like that you know and and I
think as as someone who's a Believer
there's a distinct difference between
condemnation and conviction conviction
is a healthy thing it comes from the
Holy Spirit condemnation doesn't exist
for the believer Romans 8 1 says there's
therefore there's no condemnation for
those who in Christ Jesus so wrestling
with those two things but
I don't have to necessarily surrender to
my conviction yeah and if I separate
myself from that conviction because I'm
disconnected neurologically because I've
done this thing enough where I've
Justified it
now it's not that big of a deal right
and now I no longer feel convicted by it
because
anybody seriously believe it's not a sin
does any I know plenty of people are
going to say right it's not a sin it's
fine it's healthy I don't you've got the
New York Health Department saying it's
good for you to you know do what Woody
Allen euphemistically called sex with
someone you love right but
does it nobody Norm McDonald had a whole
bid on this yeah where he was doing a
show I think in San Francisco and Norm
gets up he goes yeah sex is a filthy
shameful disgusting thing that's
obviously only meant for procreation and
the audience is shocked by this he goes
ah you know how like you have a
one-night stand or you're gonna do it uh
what's the first thing you do you you uh
close the blinds yeah this is not the
kind of thing you're doing for everybody
to see so just any or people just you're
kidding themselves right yeah oh for
sure I mean it's just the reality that
you're forming a relationship with a
screen in your hand so not only is it it
integrates selfishness it it dissipates
your ability to execute self-control uh
you you're becoming a poor lover like
you're training yourself to finish
quickly like it's it's contradictory to
anything that is applicable to love or
being a good spouse right there's no
there's no positive thing about it
unless you're saying well I just to give
in to my desires give in to my flesh
well Romans 12 1 says that we're a
Living Sacrifice and we're to be in in
Romans you know 12 2 goes on to talk
about we're not to be conformed by the
world but rather be we're to be
transformed by renewing of our mind
we're to go through this metamorphosis
so that
we can know what the perfect will of God
is so we can appear in contrast right so
if if I I can't understand what is
reality and what is me giving into my
flesh yeah if if I that becomes blurry
then sure I'm gonna try to adjust it
well that's the the traditional
understanding of
two Wills right you know the things I
want to do I don't do the things I don't
want to do yeah around the seven yeah so
the the rational will is supposed to
mediate between the perfect will of God
and your fleshy right bodily repetitive
will yeah and this was you didn't need a
PhD in philosophy to understand this for
most of history now nobody seems to know
anything but but that was my feelings
are my identity right yeah exactly and
now people is what's propagated yes and
so since we're talking about religion
when you say that looking at porn and
you know doing what people do when they
look at porn yeah is giving yourself a
relationship with your hand right and
the Pamela Anderson or something and a
screen as my college buddy I don't think
he coined it but I did laugh when he
mentioned that line uh and a screen
though yeah is it darker than just the
screen is it more spiritual than just
the screen absolutely is it just demons
are you just is it an is it a liturgical
act of worship
to Demons well I'm gonna put it really
bluntly well if if if your objective
when it comes to sex is to as a Believer
if your objective is to be between a man
and a wife and that to be a
representation of Christ in his church
like what place does that have and John
10 10 talks about how how the enemy
wants to kill still and Destroy well if
if I can still the way that you see
intimacy I can I can cause you to create
an idol and all of a sudden this thing
becomes an idol and I'm disillusioned
into the fact to believe that this is
something I need and it's a real
addiction like neurologically like you
will form an addiction something that
you do over and over again that gives
you a you know this dopamine hits your
brain it makes you feel good
those it yeah it makes you feel good but
you're you're forming this artificial
relationship with this fictitious
reality right there's I guess my
question though is
is it it's a fictitious reality in that
these performers are not really the
characters that they portrayed not
really their stage names but but I
wonder in a deeper sense is it is it a
real thing
are you forming a an intimate
relationship with the principalities and
powers and spiritual wickedness in other
places absolutely well I mean that
that's what the enemy tried to do to
Jesus if I can get you to to compromise
your identity I can get you to
compromise further
it's like you know even even in the
garden did did God really say that
did he really say that right do you know
providentially just today
I mentioned something about Genesis on
my Daily Show and someone wrote in and
said well Michael the quote you said
that's not the first thing that the
serpent says in the garden actually the
first thing is this question the step
what is did hold on a second yeah did
God really say did he really mean you
were gonna die yeah it's not quite that
yeah so to question that identity and
then
even now you see all these headlines
about uh the sex worker writes and all
especially all of the sexual Revolution
LGBT stuff we're heading into the month
of June which is now one of the 12
months of the year dedicated to the the
rainbow I think this pretty soon they're
going to invent a 13th month to be
another gay pride month so we're heading
into June and you're seeing all these
corporations begin to really push this
stuff and I can't help but notice
one of the guys I think it's actually a
girl who identifies as a guy who who
designed the pride clothing Pride the
queen of all vices yeah right the
deadliest of the seven deadly sins yeah
well and in addition to that they use
the rainbow which is a a symbolism of
God's promise right did not destroy the
world right one of the holiest symbols
ever yeah now yeah the like one of the
first covenants right and get and and a
symbol given to us by God and and but
one of the people who designed the
clothing for Target is an overt Satanist
and I can't help but notice whenever I
see these viral Clips go around of some
Pro sex work person or some Pro only
Advanced person or some show for the
porn industry will come out there's very
often
demonic devilish imagery that goes along
with that horns and Tails and pitchforks
well yeah Las Vegas is Sin City it's
just
how come it's always these same images
and these same symbols all of which have
been considered demonic and occult for
thousands of years yeah even even you
know it to even further it on like in
the goat as well the goat yeah so the
goat like the so I saw this on the
target clothing yeah
there was there was a guy who he had
goat horns on his head yeah and then he
had a goat thing on a head on his shirt
which was some satanic thing right and
you see it in the depiction of demon
like Baphomet or somebody yeah does that
feature into porn or no I I mean I would
just point it yeah the fur like the Deep
symbolism didn't points directly to evil
but to your point yes it is is a direct
correlation of evil but
where you know where God is absent there
is there is only evil yeah so I would
say yes like to your points like it's a
direct window into evil into demons into
all these things
um and that's why it's so dark and it
leads to death and to to the person
advocating for the porn industry saying
well how else could this person you know
provide for their family they had to do
that this is their right who in their
right mind
wants to be a prostitute yeah like no
one wants that yeah
it's just a lie like but but no one
wants that you you don't wake up yeah or
you don't go to bed at night you lay
down your head on a pillow and you think
I'm so proud of myself because I'm
selling myself for sex yeah you don't do
that it's contradictory to the way that
you're wired re it transcends belief
yeah but but often when you push people
on this
you'll say well I have to be a stripper
I have to be a prosecutor I have to be
important or something like that you say
well why can't you
but work it in the service industry I've
worked plenty of service industry jobs
but I would go even further than that
okay well here's what I would challenge
there's something that happened to you
that made you believe that you could not
pursue the thing that you're passionate
about and because you can't pursue the
thing you're passionate about because
the trauma yeah whether it happened to
you or you did it you now Define
yourself through the lens of that trauma
and you see yourself as incapable of
doing the thing that you want to do so
there's nothing left for you to do
but to compromise but but isn't there
compromise is easy right but I I just
mean since we all encounter the service
industry throughout the day you go again
yeah and you think okay
many if not most of us have worked these
jobs at some point yeah they're not the
most technically difficult jobs pulling
a good shot of espresso actually is kind
of difficult but but still you can learn
how to do it but very often what people
will say is well
but they can't make it as much money you
can make more money per hour well yeah
it's so cracked that's what I think like
well okay you can make it you can make a
decent enough living though like a you
smuggle you know weapons or whatever you
know there's there's a variety of things
that you could do that you shouldn't do
that you could make money right but just
because you could doesn't mean you
should right now right I just I could
see all of those Temptations especially
for people it's just so chilling to hear
what that agent asked you the first
thing hey tell me about your childhood
yeah yeah it's almost broken home
perfect oh absolutely you're looking for
someone who you can manipulate based on
the way that they see themselves
because if you don't have a foundation
to stand on you're gonna You're Gonna Be
With the Wind yeah or you're going to go
into whatever way that sounds good
because you don't know who you are and
you're looking to the world to conform
you so how do we fix it I know it's a
Fallen World people really ought to
focus uh first on their relationship
with God yeah and they want to you know
work on sanctification and virtue and
all the rest of that yeah that doesn't
let the politics off the hook we live in
public
yeah we prosecuted pornographers for
porn yeah for obscenity very recently
during the Bush Administration Bush
number two yeah there were pornographers
who were sent to prison for for just not
for child porn not for other just for
smut yeah can we just do that why is it
that an eight-year-old can log on to any
of these porn sites and watch whatever
they want yeah so I had the opportunity
to speak at Capitol Hill and were
advocating for the earned act so the
earning act has three three different
um pieces the most important piece would
be creating a solidified way of
verifying one's identity through a
government-issued ID okay so that so
actually uh Louisiana and two other
states Utah and I forget the third have
implemented this legislation even though
it hasn't passed yet so you you have to
be 18 and what what's crazy is like
right now in other places you can just
go to a site and make up a birthday or
just click are you 18 sure
and you can and it bypasses that I used
to do that on Tobacco websites for
cigars yeah January 1st 1902. okay
that's my birthday yeah there's there's
no barrier yeah um so so so advocating
for that
um incredibly helpful and just making
people aware of like how it's impacting
people like average age of exposure 11
years old wow 84 of people who see porn
under the age of 15 for the first time
it's incidental exposure someone's
looking for something on you know
they're doing a biology project they
scroll down one too many times and all
of a sudden they see something as
pornographic if if there's no barrier if
there's no
um you know if you don't have some kind
of safety you know controls on your your
smart device it's so easily accessible
yeah because back in the day for me
um you know it's like if you stayed up
too late like skidamax and hbr you know
but because of streaming and because of
cell phones it's so easy accessible that
you don't have to look for it's going to
find you right right and to your point
it's become so normative
and then like only fans and so on and so
on it's become so normative
that's so prevalent that it's just out
there for everyone
and it's like when something becomes the
norm it's like well
that might be bad but it's just it's the
way it is people are going to see it I
also think even I mean we're talking
about hardcore pornography industry
preying on people yeah but
I I was just back in Los Angeles you
drive down Sunset Boulevard and look at
just regular Billboards yeah pretty
risque or you go on Instagram yeah and
just regular con like of people you know
maybe because I worked in La for a bit
some of my old Pals from out there are a
little more risque to begin with but
you that kind of content the content and
advertising it's all kind of
Shades of Gray well yeah like you you
look at the laws around advertisement
they're from you know 10 15 years ago
where porn wasn't so prevalent but to
advertise on Twitter that that the the
agent consents 13. so you can advertise
whatever you want to 13 and up but
no one foresaw right the fact that
people will be advertising pornography
but that industry to my point 100
billion dollar industry yeah so there's
that much money at stake so you're
asking me to change that legislation
right when it's making that much money
right it's like even knowing it's
contributing to rape culture is
contributing to sex trafficking is
contributing to it's insane so there's
this person um her name's Heidi Olson
she's a critical care nurse in Kansas
City Missouri
50 plus cases
per year of a sibling raping
their you know a little boy raping a
little girl or a little boy raping his
brother
multiple cases it's it's it's this is
happening in Kansas City Missouri 100 of
the time that kid watched so much porn
that he went and did that did the is I
assume this is a spike in these numbers
like I assume this is not a normal thing
that nurses have been observing for
unfortunately she sees it so much that
that's all she does
man
so that's you know I had the opportunity
to partner with nicosi so the National
Coalition opposing sexual exploitation
and Exodus Cry and we were at Capitol
Hill advocating for that legislation we
sat down with different you know state
representatives and there's uh there was
a a woman there and she was sharing her
story where she was dating someone and
then they went to Vegas and they while
they're in Vegas this person actually
drugs her and he rapes her and films it
and then he has a few friends come and
they rape her and they all film it and
he puts this on PornHub and it stays on
PornHub for two years it becomes very
popular it becomes monetized eventually
the person's identified it's taken down
he gets arrested and charged yet the
images still exist on Google and Google
says there's no clear you know there's
there's no Clarity regarding this
person's Senators yeah there's no
consent there's no there's no clear like
you know around the whole consent thing
there's no there's there's no clear sign
of this person being objectified or
raped or anything like that so they left
the imagery up
even with that even if the guy gets
arrested right
so so so that's the reality that we live
in here too I mean this is a good
framing of the issue because it's it'll
probably resonate more
you say well obviously it's about sexual
crimes and sure breaking laws that are
already in the books
but isn't there also an argument
that if you if 90 of men are looking at
this stuff or have looked at it at some
point pretty it's probably much higher
than that yeah
and this is a regular problem that is
constantly degrading people's views of
themselves views of other people you're
uh communing with demons let's just call
it what it is
how do you have a good country if
a hundred percent of men or thereabouts
and a and a large number of women yeah
are perpetually in a state of mortal sin
yeah is isn't that a problem for the
political Community to try to work on
absolutely absolutely and I think that
and what you're wrestling with is
a tremendous amount of money money and
power and power yeah and then and then
also this false belief that I should be
able to do what I whatever I feel like
yeah right and then and then that's
Freedom yeah Freedom porn is freedom
isn't it what's crazy it from you know
from a Christian perspective like
Liberty is actually
the choice to be able to say no to the
things I ought not do right even when I
want you to do that right even when I
don't want to do that right that you
know it's like Galatians like five you
know 22 and 23 he talks about you know
the last thing fruits of the spirit
self-control yeah like self-control is
evidence of the holy spirit that was the
idea of liberal education and the
liberal arts was to discipline yourself
to be able to control your base
appetites and desires right for a higher
Freedom right because the freedom the
freedom to shoot heroin or something
yeah that's not Freedom nobody really
thinks that's Freedom same goes for
porns yeah you know if you told John
Adams and George Washington Thomas
Jefferson hey the freedom thing it's
worked it's working out really great
yeah we here in 2023 guys you can look
at as much weirdo porn as you want and
as young as 13. yeah I think they would
they would say you know what
this country
forget about it let's forget about it we
made a mistake let's go back that's
obviously not what they thought freedom
was yeah 100 yeah I mean in like to to
even paint it like a darker picture it's
like you uh there was a Netflix
documentary that I was watching uh like
a year or two ago and this person he was
wrongly persecuted and he was in prison
and now he had a show where he was
traveling and just this is what this
prison looks like this is what like the
experience is this is you know the
geographical location so on and so on
and he was in this one prison and he
found out that 84 percent of the guys
there
um this is a different country yeah but
84 of the guys there they both they had
been convicted of rape and it's like
that's an astronomical amount so he he
you know asked you know like 50 people
or so like you know how did this happen
why this happened and he kept getting
the same answer in their culture men
were more important than women and and
sex was something that a man was owed
pornography
it portrays the same thing that you
should be able to walk into a room yeah
yeah
and just have sex with someone yeah and
then also you know in the 80th
percentile like all pornography has some
level of violence in it so now you're
you're digesting something you're you're
developing an appetite for when you
develop an appetite for something that
is not only opposite of what you were
designed to desire it's actually
contrary to what's reality but if you if
you get this appetite for it you're
gonna feel insatiable until you partake
this is something that it's amazing how
people have forgotten what taste and
desire are and what they're like no
child starts out with a hankering for
Scotch right no 10 year old says I could
really go for a scotch yeah Scotch is an
acquired taste oysters are an acquired
taste yeah caviar I don't know whatever
these things are required
tobacco probably and but then you
acquire them and then you desire them
and then sometimes once you acquire The
Taste for Scotch you desired rum or
tequila or something yeah
did you see an interview with Andy
Wachowski who's one of the guys behind
the Matrix movies and he and his brother
both became trans at a certain but kind
of odd the guys who created The Matrix
about this disconnect between reality
and the virtual reality these guys both
become trans and Andy Wachowski one of
the brothers gives an interview and and
he says oh yeah porn was what led me to
my transgender identity I watched a
bunch of porn and then I started
identifying as trans and there were
there were many such cases well Ted
Bundy Ted Bundy was super into porn
right well yeah very into porn and he
actually said porn was the thing that
led him to this thing and this thing and
this thing and then I mean that's the
way it is like you you know you at one
point in my life I could drink one Bud
Light and get a buzz you know and then
you know you need more to just crack in
a crystal meth or something yeah like
you you go on this trajectory where I
need more of this thing to get this
feeling that I had well I think of
probably a caricature of what risque
material was like in the 19th century
which is you know a woman that big
frilly dressed oh I'm going to show a
little bit of my ankle or something and
and but obviously the way that these
base or appetites work you're never
satisfied so so when you say okay
increasingly
porn is violent and people are consuming
more violent porn obviously this is
cultivating certain tastes and desires
and so if an eight-year-old or whatever
a ten-year-old gets hooked on to porn
it's not that he's going to immediately
start looking at weird transsexual billy
goat porn but it's going to be that he
looks more yeah he's going to look at a
naked lady it's like he's going to look
at a Playboy or something and then it's
going to be this harder thing and this
harder thing and then pretty it gets
pretty dark yeah
pretty quick just judging by the
statistics yeah I mean well even like
psychologically you see
um I think it was at the 80s uh there
was someone who won a Nobel Prize around
this research
um is his last name was Tim Bergen and
he did this research around supernormal
stimulus and he uh studied a a level of
uh so he said he studied this butterfly
and there was a species of butterfly
where he created a female butterfly and
but he made brighter better you know 3D
and put this butterfly into space in the
male butterflies tried to mate with this
butterfly and obviously didn't work but
then the byproduct of that was they
started ignoring the female butterflies
and then they started fighting among
each other and then they started dying
out and it's a really you know it's a
great correlation to what porn is
because if you're Desiring something
that's a fictitious reality you're going
to become insatiable for it and you're
seeing men then you know struggling with
erectile dysfunction you're seeing
people you know being unfaithful to
their spouse you're seeing all these
things because there's a disconnect from
what is real in contrast to what is fake
like the like the movie Inception you
know there's this fight in this elevator
scene it's one of my favorite movies and
you you don't see that and you think man
they just you know one day they must
have just you know gotten that elevator
and and threw that together no there was
there was choreography there were CGI
there was editing there was there's all
this stuff that went into there there
were actors they were paid to be there
there was a director
like pornography is the same thing
you're creating a fantasy that doesn't
exist that's that's creating the
experience but if you ex if you believe
that experience to be true and then you
develop a does a desire or a taste for
it you go to seek it out
and you can't find it you're gonna be
you're gonna end up doing things that
you never thought you would do because
it's even
not just the surreality of the porn film
sure it's the surreality of
the consumer yeah where you say as
you're describing well no that that's
just compartmentalized over here that
thing that I'm doing you know on my
computer on my phone that's not really
me right that's just like a thing I
that's a different guy yeah he probably
has a different name yeah that has a
note but we're human beings we're
integrated beings so obviously you can't
just compartmentalize that yeah and so
that is going to affect your
marriage that's going to affect your
relationships it's going to affect your
your desires and and even the moral
reality okay I'm only only Joshua is
morally culpable right but stage name
guy yeah there's no consequences it's
not real life yeah and I think even more
so that you're seeing these people
develop you know the these appetites
watching pornography and they end up
with someone you know they they get
married number one believing the lie
that if I get married my porn addiction
will go away it doesn't and now I have
these these appetites for these things
that I've developed you know a desire
for yeah and maybe my wife isn't
fulfilling them and now I'm going to
bring these presuppositions about what
sex is supposed to be into my marriage
bed and then if they don't meet my
desire I'm going to continue watching
porn or I'm going to go outside of the
the marriage because I believe I need
this thing to be satisfied where God
never intended mayor marriage to be
about sex it's a great part of marriage
but marriage in itself is not only about
sex right and but it's certainly not
about steriles sure but it's like it's
about well because like it's it's again
it's like it's idolatry if I make sex
god I'm gonna do any any and everything
in my power to submit and surrender to
the God of Sex right right but even the
idea that porn is without consequence
you know what people view sex is without
consequence but of course marriage
traditionally understood is
intended for the good of the spouses and
for the sake of the generation and
education of children yeah that it's a
real love a love that is so real that it
actually becomes in fleshed in this real
new person yeah who and hopefully many
new people who you know are a result of
that love yeah
we divorce all even our popular culture
yeah we live in a very contraceptive
culture yeah well yes well and also it's
just there's there's a there's a huge
difference between love and lust yeah I
think they're so different they're not
similar they're polar opposite yeah one
selfish one selfless yes you know one's
very sacrificial and one cost you
something and one's easy and it's and
you you're compromised right and what's
about me one's about self-control one's
about giving in to myself right I mean
the one of the traditional definitions
of Love Is that love is to will the good
of the other person yeah for their own
sake yeah not from and so obviously
that's the opposite but
I just I I was talking with a friend of
mine
I think there was some headline about
how in Japan people want to look at porn
more than they want to date or have sex
yeah and my friend said that's insane
could you imagine you got you got an
opportunity to sleep with a woman or to
look at porn could you imagine someone
choosing porn yeah I said I totally can
understand that well yeah you I mean
speaking in that culture you go into a
place where you don't even have to
interact with a human person to get food
I mean we're living in a culture where
people don't want to pick up a phone and
call somebody it's only text or we want
to talk to a screen we don't want any
people have so much Social Anxiety I
said in that culture yeah of course
the the porn is requires no effort is
never going to judge you there's no
rejection there's no rejection and the
porn can be whatever stuff you type in
you're gonna have like three furries and
an alien and I don't know whatever and
gosh like speaking of that I I was
speaking of first I was I was at uh a
conference yeah um so it's called think
media and it's a Christian Conference
and bring in different speakers about
different topics and the objective is
for you to be able to think critically
about you know things that are going on
in culture and be able to speak into
them as Christian leaders and uh there
was this person just talking about the
just the insane stuff going on inside of
schools and uh I I
I did not know this but in Washington
state there is multiple schools that
have rooms with
kitty litter in them for people who
identify as furries to urinate this
can't be real this is real I this Camp I
refuse to believe that this is real this
is real
so there's there's there tax dollars
have gone to building rooms that have
kitty litter in them there's litter
boxes that you know adolescents go into
and urinating and the teachers will get
penalized you know that they'll they'll
you know their their jobs are on the
line for them to communicate with them
based on who how they identify though I
prefer to just
reject the possibility that this could
even be real in another sense I I feel
better about that than I do about some
guy going into the girls room if a guy
thinks he's a cat and he wants to go to
a litter box yeah
at least he's not invading a woman's
private space you know it's not exactly
uh ordered living yeah probably not
conducive to human flourishing right
well like even like more detrimental
than that there's legislation in
Washington State trying to be passed
where 13 and up you could say I I want
to change my gender and then they then
you know they they contact government
Authority and without any consent or
knowledge of the parents they saw the
child and then they mutilate them or
provide them with whatever procedure or
medication
using tax dollars to do so
and the parents have no say so about the
matter I saw a headline in the
Associated Press which has become very
left-wing used to used to pretend to at
least be down the middle now it's a very
left-wing activist news outlet and the
headline said something to the effect of
Washington state protects trans kids
from parents
thought
who's doing the protecting and right
what does that protection look like yeah
that's pretty dark it's I mean for me
it's just incredibly sad to to be at a
place you know I'm I'm a father of of
three very young boys so four three and
one and
um
how can that be
how in what place do we get where adults
are allowing kids to tell them
they feel some sort of way that's been
propagated to them like through a person
or you know an organization or whatever
where have they heard it yeah because
this is not a thought that enters
someone's mind normally
um
how do I get to a point where we're
allowing kids at 13 years old that can't
vote can't see a rated R movie
um can't you know do it's number like
numerous things
decide they can make a decision that's
going to change their life well so the
answer how do we get to that point is in
part because of Perpetual ubiquitous
degrading sin yeah so then having come
full circle and you've come out of it
and more than full circle and yeah
you're in a much better place now do you
ever have contact with
the people from the foreign industry
from your old life do you ever reach
back out to them do you ever
say like hey guys is a better option
yeah
um so for me uh so I got to the place
that I got to in life through you know
number one you know have a relationship
with God
um developing uh an understanding of the
Bible and allowing it to conform my life
in contrast to the world conforming uh
me or my feelings or my past or my
feelings and as I go on that journey I
go to counseling as well and um and part
of that was I had to kind of dismantle
and destroy everything that I thought to
be true yeah and it early on like me
becoming you know a Christian I was like
I'm Gonna Save the World you know and so
I would I reached back out to those
people and I started you know
interacting with them on social media
and like talking with them and what I
found was I still had a lot of trauma
that I was carrying and it was actually
unhealthy for me yeah to to see the
things they were posting and and you
know even though I was able to
acknowledge that this is not something
that I would ever want to be part of
again or and then it you know that was
bad but it was impacting me negatively
so I had a distance myself from them but
to your point
I I didn't continue reaching out but
what they saw
and many people have saw is
I wanted to take my life because I
thought I would never
be a father
I would never get married I thought like
sure I could convince a girl to marry me
like sure I could get a girl pregnant
but I would never have the capacity to
be a father
I've never had the capacity to be a
husband I think most guys no matter how
well adjusted you are you think that's a
lot of responsibility yeah but I I think
pretty much every man who has become a
father sure says that especially someone
who's got this fairly colorful and
dramatic past yeah it's going to feel
that especially yeah and then in in
addition to I thought okay for me if if
I'm not leading something or being
creative it's like detrimental to me
emotionally like I need to be able to be
creative in a way that impacts people
and I thought well there's no way that
I'll be able to do that like there no
one's hiring me for like any kind of
acting job that's legitimate I'm not
doing any kind of modeling probably just
not healthy for me to do so what
organization is going to take me
seriously like who am I going to
contribute to in any capacity like all
so I I wanted to take my life because I
thought there's things like any anything
that I long for regarding a future I
didn't think were possible
so for me I you know I I lead a very
healthy organization I I do itinerant
work you know I'm about to plan a church
I've written a book I have a healthy
family
um I I love my kids I lead my family
well
I'm doing everything I thought that
wasn't possible so when people see yeah
like it's not about my success or the
fact that you know I have this influence
or whatever like that's whatever I'm
living this healthy life and I'm full of
joy because I have these things in my
life that I didn't think possible and
you're there's no you're prudent in that
I read a book a staple of spiritual
combat cold spiritual combat by Lorenzo
scoopally it's like 500 years old and in
it he talks about the impulse to face
Temptation head on and I can overcome it
and for certain Temptations
you can and for certain temptations that
can be helpful for really taken on head
on he says sexual Temptation yeah not
one of them yeah run you've got to run
from that yeah not stick around so if
you're following these porn Affiliated
people and you're seeing that yeah
yeah it's probably going to do more harm
than good you know you've got to be wise
as a serpent innocent as a dove yeah so
for me
um I had people in my life to say here's
how I'm feeling this is what I'm going
through this is what I'm doing it's not
a good idea because uh what what I
didn't have in my life is people to both
encourage me and correct me because we
need we need to be called up
you know and called out sometimes yeah
so for me I didn't have that so I have
anything in my life and saying hey this
is what I'm doing hey
Joshua that's not a good idea I don't
think you're in a place where this is
healthy but you know eight years later
living the life I'm living now there's
people that are in that industry that
have one foot in one foot out or maybe
have left the industry are reaching out
to me saying
um I actually left or I actually did
this because
I see what you're doing
and it's not you know there's no promise
of a wife or a husband there's no
promise of of of whatever there's no
promise of that for anybody yeah I mean
that's that's the thing is people think
well you know because I've made these
three choices I can't have a wife or
husband now some people don't get
married some some people if they do get
married can't have children yeah that's
life it's a fallen world it's a tough
place it doesn't need to make or break
your your
sanctification yeah one in the in the
beautiful thing about that so Joy is not
something that's circumstantial yeah
right Joy is something you can't obtain
on your own it's a gift that's offered
to you to be received
and it comes through a relationship with
Jesus yeah so
um for me I get to share that story it's
like how did you get from A to B I was
like well there's there's one answer and
he's a person he has a name his name is
Jesus but for me it was it was Jesus you
know so where again there's so many
aspects of like I'm sure that we would
differ in in certain things regarding
theology but what I love is the
commitment to like we would differ in
that you know what what sanctification
looks like you know in a moment in
contrast to it being Progressive and you
would say it's in a moment right okay
um topic for another time yeah yeah sure
sure yeah yeah so I mean just like you
know you got you you've got salvation
sanctification justification and what
those things look like but Salvation is
Progressive in that you are
progressively being changed yeah yeah so
progressively there's this journey that
you go on and as you're going on that
Journey like you have to take steps of
faith and those steps have to be away
from like second Corinthians 5 17 is
real for the life of a Believer the the
person that you used to be is dead
and now you have a new identity a new
heart a new purpose but you have to move
towards that purpose yeah right because
you still have free will yeah you have
the free will to to reject God's grace
yeah to go back right I mean and so for
me it's like oh step by step these are
the steps that I took but it started
with this one Catalyst that is
irreplaceable there's this one piece of
the puzzle yeah that you can't replace
but these steps along the way and people
are seeing that and they're responding
to the fact it's like it's not that you
know you have this or you have that
is you've got this joy that
I didn't think I could ever have and you
believe that this uh inarticulable
undeniable joy that lives within you
yeah yeah but it's like like I want that
but the fact that you have it
yeah it it's intriguing enough to me to
ask the question it reminds me of a line
from C.S Lewis when he said when you're
a kid
you think chocolate is the greatest
thing you cannot imagine anything
greater than chocolate yeah if someone
came up to you these days I guess this
would happen in a kindergarten classroom
but someone comes up to you and says hey
you ever hear about sex
and you're a kid you say I don't know I
don't know what sex is yeah a guy says
well you know sex is great it's better
than chocolate yeah and if you're a kid
you have to think well I guess sex
involves chocolate because chocolate is
the best thing so whatever is better
it's got to involve chocolate yeah and
you don't realize there's something
better and unfortunately in our culture
that's kind of where people stop sure it
would seem a lot today it's about okay
no you're right sex is better than
chocolate and sex is the best thing but
there is
an even better thing yeah there are many
better things and there's an ultimately
a highest good yeah which is which is
what your desire is supposed to yeah and
it's like and I love that you know so
because like suicidal ideation is is
part of my story it's like there's a
project that I'm working on where
there's these you know this organization
called stay here and there are
organizations around that you know you
know every 40 seconds someone dies of
suicide
so
we've we've we did one project where you
would appreciate this we we just took a
bunch of different Christian
um influencers and we just read through
the Apostles Creed and we read through
the Apostle screen that was it and but
it was not one person it was many people
it wasn't you know one organization it
was many organizations many people one
message one unified message a reflection
of John 17. yeah this unified message
when people see you know when the world
sees us you'll see a reflection of
Christ so
um we did that and then our next project
is we're working with NFL quarterbacks
so we've got like 15 Super Bowl winner
Super Bowl winners like multiple like
Hall of Famers and we're doing this
video and they're just simply saying
stay here
your life matters yeah you're loved
because
that's what I that's what I didn't think
I didn't think that I was loved I didn't
think that I mattered and just seeing
that God is allowing me to be just a
small part in projects like that and and
do some of the things I'm doing and live
the life that I'm living
um
you know I I wake up every day and it's
like a dream you know I have friends
who got to your point where they were
just about to do it
and I have friends who did it I have
multiple friends who did it yeah
and
you think what that's that thin
line that moment because it'd be one
thing if if you just knew a lot of
people not a lot but some number of
people who came up to the brink and then
they pulled back and you said okay well
maybe that's just a feature of suicidal
ideation as you get up to a point and
then you go no further yeah but knowing
you know more people than I do who
killed themselves you know no people go
over that line yeah that's that's a real
cliff and people fall off it all the
time yeah and you got up that close yeah
and then
a bank teller said my name
and what's Wild so that my my friend
Jacob who who's the CEO and founder of
that organization stay here he he says
simply
the it's the easiest uh it's it's the
easiest
um thing that you could ever you know
just dealing with suicide it's much
easier than you would think in that the
person just needs to be asked hey are
you thinking about taking your life
and more often than not research says
they'll say yes
and then once they say it
it becomes real
and then you can have a conversation
[Music]
like the guy the guy who jumps off a
building anyone who survives that says
instantly they're regrettable well in
the air like many times I I forget I
think someone jumped off the like the
the Golden Gate Bridge the Golden Gate
Bridge or whatever which how they lived
I'm not sure but he's like literally the
second you did it
it's like
God help me you know yeah right right
and and so just to even put that out
there I mean
getting back to I guess the top point of
the yeah
conversation the the power of a word and
the power of a name yeah to identify
things and distinguish between them I
mean so much of the political
political correctness or this kind of
agenda that seems so destructive is
about
calling things by fake names yeah in
order to manipulate how people view
themselves yeah and I love like in
Hebrew I mean my name means Yahweh is
salvation
of course yeah and then so our our first
son uh we named him Cannon so canon in
Hebrew means measuring stick so for me
never thought I'd be a father so he was
the measure of God's grace to me and my
wife
[Music]
can't beat that as a place to end Joshua
pleasure to have you yeah absolutely
thanks for coming on yeah thank you